schweres erdbeben der stärke 7 am
mittelmeer
betroffen sind die türkei und
griechenland dutzende häuser stürzen ein
anwohner suchen nach vielen
verschütteten menschen nach dem ersten
schrecken dann noch die meldung gar
nicht auf das fest platz machen
warnungen von drei meter hohen wellen
erreichen die bürger dann trifft das
wasser auf das festland der türkischen
provinz ist mir die bilder sind
erschreckend
auch in griechenland wird die küste
überflutet autos werden weggespült
es ist eine katastrophe mit vielen
verletzten und möglich erweitert worden
ja also wenn man sich jetzt die bilder
die wir bisher kennen anschaut und auch
die zeit hier dieses erdbeben gedauert
hat 30 sekunden anschaut und sie wie
schnell dann zum beispiel gebäude
kollabiert sind da bleibt nicht viel
zeit um sich in sicherheit zu bringen
ich habe selber mehrfach aus
erdbebengebieten berichtet die dann auch
immer noch von nachbeben geplagt waren
was man dort tut ist natürlich erstens
immer eine tasche dabei haben mit der
man sobald sich jemand so schnell wie
möglich das haus zu verlassen auf die
straße ins freie zu rennen tatsächlich
ist das freie das einzige was
einigermaßen schutz bieten kann alles
andere was oft gesagt wird verstecken
sie sich unter dem tisch und so weiter
selbst wenn man darunter eine höhere
chance hat zu überleben wenn über ein
gebäude zusammenbricht ist das erst
natürlich ein unglaubliches gewicht und
zweitens kann es oft tage dauern bis
menschen daraus geborgen werden also das
was wir da im moment sehen lässt alles
das muss man leider sagen nichts nichts
gutes hoffen und da an und wie gesagt
man kann nur hoffen dass das was das
nachgelagerte phänomen ist nämlich eben
dieser tsunami dass das nicht so
ausfällt wie man aber auch da sehen wir
jetzt unsere zuschauer
man sieht dort auf den bildern wie sich
wie sich schiffe hineinschieben ins
landesinnere ja auf dieser wasserwand
und auch das ist etwas was wir damals in
thailand erlebt haben völlige zerstörung
völlige zerstörung dort wo das was er
sich seinen weg gebahnt hat dass schiffe
die auf häuserdächern lagen autos die in
der zweiten etage von häusern lagen von
sozialen menschlicher zivilisation ist
dort wo in tsunami einschlägt
anschließend nicht mehr viel
spürbar und erkennbar und was wäre ja
auch sehen was wir aus thailand
berichtet hast hier sehen wir noch mal
die boote die quasi völlig hilflos
einfach auf dem wasser treiben was wir
auch berichtet heißt sie vielen
schaulustigen die das einfach als
naturspektakel beobachten wie lange hat
man überhaupt in etwa zeit wie lange
dauert es bis sich so einen tsunami
aufbaut sprechen wir da von sekunden
oder wie lange dauert es bis sich die
menschen dann auch weil sie in
sicherheit bringen können wie bedrohlich
und kurzfristig ist diese situation dort
gerade also tatsächlich zieht sich das
wasser innerhalb kürzester zeit zurück
das ist wirklich so als würde die erde
sich auftun unter dem wasser und weil es
werde genau als wäre der stöpsel
rausgezogen und würde das wasser quasi
verschlucken und dann baut es sich auf
zu dieser mann sieht es auf den bildern
die wir im moment sehen auf diesen es
sieht so harmlos ist wie die schiffe
darauf haben aber man sieht dass es
wirklich wie ein block aus wasser ist ja
dass es keine welle ist wie wir es von
hurrikan auf den sondern eine einem ein
wasser blog auf dem diese boote quasi
stehen wie auf einem riesigen bulldozer
der sich der sich bewegt und dass das
wasser zurückkommt als tsunami-welle ist
etwas was tatsächlich etwas länger
dauern kann ja da können einige minuten
10 15 minuten vergehen bis diese
wassermassen ebenso als tsunami
zurückgegangen ja es also stärke 7 ein
sehr sehr starkes erdbeben im
mittelmeerraum wir wollen das noch mal
zusammenfassen ist mir ist betroffen die
türkische provinz und die griechische
insel samos das erdbeben ist so stark
gewesen dass es sogar bis nach bulgarien
und bis nach jahrzehnten spürbar war in
die griechische hauptstadt hinein 30
sekunden lang hat es gedauert es ist von
zahlreichen toten und verletzten
auszugehen uns erreichen derzeit live
bilder die zeigen wie häuser einstürzen
wie eine staubwolke über der region
wir wollen hier diese bilder nochmal
zeigen wie das hohe haus einstürzt die
erde bebte 30 sekunden lang sehr lang
für ein erdbeben das sonst in der regel
nur wenige sekunden lang dauert wir
sehen hier wie sich staubwolken über der
region auftürmen die ja ein ausmass der
zerstörung annehmen lassen dass wir
jetzt noch gar nicht abschätzen können
bei mir zu gast ist chefredaktor julian
reichelt er hat 2004 den tsunami in
südostasien begleitet und wir waren
darüber sprechen weil jetzt vor allem
die sorge und die angst vor einem
tsunami in der mittelmeerregion herrscht
sehr ungewöhnlich wir haben so etwas
noch nie beobachten können tsunamis
verorten wir sicher immer nach asien
erklären wie kann es jetzt überhaupt zu
einem tsunami in dieser region kommen
also wie genau es dazu kommt ist derzeit
noch nicht ist derzeit noch nicht genau
erkennbar
wir wissen aber dass es nicht nur eine
warnung gibt sondern das ist diese
tsunami anzeichen gibt es ist also nicht
nur eine warnung sondern wir sehen
bereits die bilder wie punktuell
zumindest wassermassen in städte in der
region ist mir eindringen und dort große
verwüstungen anrichten und wir sehen
eben dieses phänomen das wasser sich
zurückgezogen hat auch da weiß man dass
das wasser nicht friedlich zurück
plätschert sondern eben in dieser
geballten form zurückkommt wodurch das
ausgelöst ist das kann ich jetzt mal
laienhaft als ganz ausdrücklich nicht
geologe erklären bei einem bei einem bei
einem erdbeben geht es ja um
verschiebungen von erdplatten
gegeneinander und sozusagen man muss
sich das vorstellen um abbruchkanten die
entstehen die auf einmal gigantische
massen von was absacken lassen und damit
diesen sog diesen rückzug auslösen und
daneben die umgekehrte bewegung zurück
an die zurück an die küste es kann aber
zum beispiel auch der fall sein dass
berg massen kollabieren und ins wasser
kippen und dadurch gigantische tsunami
artige wellen auslösen
es gibt verschiedene modelle was genau
da passiert ist
in der region ist mir und sagen was kann
man jetzt noch nicht genau sagen was man
aber eben schon sagen kann ist dass wir
dieses phänomen tsunami das wasser zieht
sich zurück einerseits und
er kommt mit wucht zurück in die straßen
dass wir das durchaus schon sehen das
ist also schon etwas stimmt was deutlich
über eine warnung hinaus gehört ja hier
sehen wir auch noch mal die bilder wie
hilflos die boote im wasser schwimmen
sieht man auch schon was vor allem zog
sich andeutet wird es freuen einmal die
kraft dieses tores beschrieben wieder
das eben auch als reporter in thailand
war es 2004 erlebt hat wir schreiben uns
noch einmal es ist für uns unvorstellbar
hier in europa weil wir so etwas noch
nie erlebt haben man stellt sich das so
einfach formen sieht dort auch die
menschen die sie stehen und sich dieses
spektakel ansehen und sich offenbar
überhaupt nicht bewusst sind welche
wucht der wirken kann beschreiben uns
nochmal diese wucht die plötzlich das
element element wasser auslösen können
ja das element wasser trifft dort auf
die küste wie eine wand aus beton
das hat nichts von der sanften seite und
durchlässigkeit wie wir das kennen
sondern es trifft als tsunami wie gesagt
wie eine solide wand auf alles was
menschen dort gebaut und errichtet haben
auch drohte der im wasser zum beispiel
und richtet mit dem mit dem
unglaublichen gewicht was wasser in hat
was wir uns immer gar nicht vorstellen
können einen kubikmeter wasser um die
1000 kilo sowie ein wie gesagt wie ein
während vw golf ungefähr dass dasselbe
gewicht trifft mit dieser enormen wucht
eben auf die küste und gibt dabei nicht
wie wir uns das vorstellen nach umfließt
nicht das worauf es trifft sondern
schiebt das worauf es trifft vor sich
her egal ob menschen oder autos oder
gebäude jetzt sprechen wir hier von
unserem friedlichen mitteln er das wir
kennen als urlaubsregion es jetzt nicht
für hohe wellen und stürmische see
bekannt ist es denn überhaupt für
möglich dass reinen der theorie das ist
so weit kommen könnte so wie damals
video das in thailand erlebt heißt also
dass er quasi so ein großer druck in
einem doch so friedlichen mehr aufgebaut
werden kann
gott bewahre aber das meer ist dazu
durchaus in der lage und durchaus fähig
und ein erdbeben der stärke 7 in einer
solchen region ist von einer enormen
stärke und die ersten anzeichen die wir
sehen deuten darauf hin dass ich da
dieses katastrophale schauspiel der
natur in gang gesetzt hat alles was man
jetzt hoffen kann
dass das wasser andere wege findet nicht
auf diese küstenlinien trifft sondern
quasi an den küsten linien vorbei sich
den den weg bahnt aber da kann man
durchaus sagen ist das schicksal nicht
mehr in der hand der menschen die sich
da gerade befinden
bei denen natürlich unsere gedanken sind
weil es immer eine so enorme bedrohung
ist der die menschen dort gerade
ausgesetzt sind sondern das schicksal
dieser menschen befindet sich in der
hand des wasser ist wenn man so möchte
ja es bleibt wirklich so offen ist das
gut aussieht eben gerade die bilder die
wir gesehen haben liebe zuschauer die
stammen nicht etwa aus 2004 sondern sind
jetzt gerade aktuell ein erdbeben der
stärke 7 in der ägäis das zentrum liegt
in der türkischen provinz izmir uns in
der griechischen insel samos 30 sekunden
lang dauerte dieses erdbeben mit einer
solchen wucht traf es die region dass es
sogar spürbar in der griechischen
hauptstadt athen und selbst in bulgarien
die das ausmaß der zerstörung gesehen es
hier es bisher noch gar nicht absehbar
man rechnet mit zahlreichen toten und
zahlreichen verletzten und das besondere
dramatische an dieser situation jetzt
gerade ist das eine tsunami-warnung
ausgesprochen wurde
etwas was wir so in einer
mittelmeerregion bisher noch nie gesehen
haben wir sehen hier noch mal die bilder
wie er sich andeutet daher eben auch die
warnung das meer hat sich zurückgezogen
es ist teilweise aber auch überflutete
regionen bereits im ich medizin wäre wie
das wasser durch die straßen strömt
alles mitreißt was ihm in die quere
kommt hier sehen wir diese bilder die
eben etwa nicht aus 2004 stammen daran
erinnern sie ebenso stark sondern jetzt
in diesen sekunden in diesen minuten in
der mittelmeerregion ganz nah übrigens
an kreta der beliebten urlaubsregion im
moment wo viele deutsche hingereist sind
das ja jetzt während corinna zeiten noch
möglich ist dorthin zu reisen aber das
zentrum wie gesagt liegt in der
türkischen provinz izmir und der
griechischen insel samos und bei mir zu
gast ist unser chefredakteur julian
reichelt 2004 begleitete er in der in
austin osten südostasien in thailand den
dramatischen tsunami damals in einem
weihnachtstage der so viele todesopfer
fordert sind es jetzt bei mir im studio
wir wollen darüber sprechen wie
überhaupt welche auswirkungen so ein
tsunami haben kann und wie es überhaupt
möglich ist das jetzt in europa im
mittelmeer eine tsunami-warnung herrscht
wir haben eben gerade die bilder gesehen
wie boote schon hilflos durch die
straßen tanzen ja bilder die dich sehr
stark an das erinnern was du 2004 als
reporter erlebt hast berichte uns einmal
von seinen eindrücken haben alle noch
vieles lebhaft vor augen waren aber alle
nicht dabei gott sei dank kann man sagen
was hast du damals dort erlebt ja es war
tatsächlich eine szenerie wie wir uns
das niemals hätten ausmalen können dass
es so etwas überhaupt gibt es war
tatsächlich einfach nichts mehr übrig
wir waren damals in der thailändischen
regierung kalakh unterwegs beliebte
urlaubsland es war tatsächlich nichts
mehr übrig von dem was menschen dort
erbaut unterrichtet hatten sondern es
war einfach alles in trümmern alles von
den baum bedienteil angefangen die
umgeknickt waren wie streichhölzer bis
hin zu den häusern wir haben jetzt
übrigens auch meldung dass sich ähnliche
phänomene auch gerade auf wie diese
wellen die wir eben gesehen haben auf
samos abspielen also auch in
griechenland scheint auf einmal nicht
nur die türkei davon betroffen und was
was mir in erinnerung geblieben ist ist
dass wir ein weil man sich nicht
vorstellen kann wie sich so eine diese
welle überhaupt aufbaut dass wir damals
in dieser totalen trümmerlandschaft
einen jungen deutschen trafen der als
einzig scheinbar einzig überlebender
durch durch diese trümmer ging und nach
seine freundin suchte und uns dann fragt
ob wir wüssten wann der bus nach bangkok
bangkok geht war offenkundig bei
offenkundig unter schwerstem shop von
diesen ereignissen und wir haben gesagt
hier gibt keinen bus nach nach bangkok
mehr und haben ihnen dann mit ihm
gesprochen und dabei herausgefunden dass
er morgens mit als er war mit einer
gruppe von freunden dort um 10 freunde
wenn ich das richtig erinnere und war
morgens mit einem boot rausgefahren zum
tauchen und hatte gemerkt dass sich das
boot einmal gehoben hatte erstaunlich
gedachte dachte an eine große welle und
das war der tsunami der unter seinem
tauchboot quasi durch geflossen ist auf
die küstenregionen und als er zurückkam
war von dieser küstenregionen nichts
mehr übrig und von seinen freunden
nichts mehr offenbar sind es tatsächlich
eine naturgewalt wie man sich das nicht
vorstellen kann und noch ein
interessantes detail zu diesem wasser
was sich zurückzieht damals war das buch
der schwarm von frank schätzing der
absolute weihnachts bestseller und ich
habe tatsächlich damals viele deutsche
familien getroffen
die überlebt haben weil sie dieses buch
gelesen hatten oder weil einer in ihrer
familie dieses buch am pool gelesen
hatte denn in diesem buch geht es um
einen tsunami und in diesem buch wird
dieses phänomen dass das wasser sich
zurückzieht beschrieben und mehrere
menschen damals haben wir gesagt dass
sie vor diesem tsunami dann dass sie das
als tsunami erkannt haben und die flucht
rechtzeitig ergriffen haben eben weil
sie in dem buch schon über die seite
hinaus gelesen hatten in dem das
beschrieben ist aber die wucht dieses
wir haben dieser katastrophalen
naturphänomen mit sich bringt das ist
etwas was man sich nicht vorstellen kann
wenn man das nicht wenn man das nicht
mal erlebt hat und des preises an wir
haben auch bilder eben jetzt aktuell die
zeigen wie menschen an den am hafen
stehen und das ganze als naturspektakel
beobachten wir sehen wie sich das wasser
zurückgezogen hat handy videos davon
gemacht werden und die menschen
überhaupt nicht wahrnehmen in welcher
potenziell bedrohliche gefährlichen lage
sie sich jetzt gerade befinden wir haben
auch darüber gesprochen wie viel zeit
überhaupt noch bleibt und wie man sich
richtig verhält in so einer situation
wir sehen sie filmen in ruhe die boote
die jetzt im sand liegen das meerwasser
hat sich komplett zurückgezogen man
sieht dass die ganze bucht leer ist
sieht man hier sehen wir das rote sich
einfach wie spielzeugautos über das
wasser bewegen gar nicht mehr unter
kontrolle zu kriegen sind und das hast
du ja auch in thailand beobachtet die
ihn nicht vorgewarnt waren sind eben die
dann dastehen und das ganze als
naturspektakel beobachten wie sollte man
sich verhalten dass es vorher einmal
hier angesprochen wie man sich verhalten
kann wenn man dort steht und das gefühl
hat das meer zieht sich zurück
jetzt im moment herrscht in der
mittelmeerregion chaos zahlreiche häuser
sind zusammengestürzt werden bilder von
menschen gesehen die auf den straßen
sind wir haben durchflutete straßen
gesehen und werden zerstörung gesehen
was sollten diese menschen in dieser
situation jetzt mit einer
tsunami-warnung hier in europa machen ja
viele menschen befinden sich gerade in
der situation ich glaube wir damit seine
grafik vorbereitet die uns einmal zeigt
wo sich dieses epizentrum befindet und
wer in den letzten jahren im urlaub war
im mittelmeer in der mittelmeerregion in
der türkei in griechenland der wird das
auf der landkarte erkennen der wird
sehen und wieder erkennen wo sich eben
dieses epizentrum befindet das ist genau
der die region der gsv sich viele
beliebte in deutschland beliebte
urlaubsinsel befinden und allen menschen
die sich dort in der region gerade
befinden kann man natürlich nur sagen
wann und und menschen in solchen
situationen sind wenn sie diese sie dort
auf diese situation treffen dass das
wasser sich schlagartig zurück zieht
viel schneller als man das jetzt von der
nordsee zum beispiel kennt wenn sich die
elbe einstellt oder ankündigt wenn sich
das wasser so zurückzieht das deutet auf
ein katastrophal und katastrophales und
verheerendes naturereignis nämlich ein
tsunami hin und das einzige was man tun
kann ist so weit weg wie möglich von der
küste und so hoch wie möglich
interessanterweise damals beim tsunami
in thailand haben wir mit einem besitzer
einer elefanten farmen gesprochen der
überlebt hatte weil er den elefanten
seinen elefanten hinterher gelaufen ist
die aus einem massiven holz gitter
ausgebrochen sind weil sie eben gespürt
haben
mit ihrer beeindruckenden intuition was
dort passiert und der besitzer dieser
elefanten hat sich auf die intuition
seiner tiere verlassen ist ihnen
hinterher gerannt in einen wald der
höher gelegen war und den dazu nahmen
mit deswegen nicht erreicht hat daran
erinnere ich mich auch den instinkt der
tiere der offenbar wirklich nicht zu
unterschätzen ist in solchen situationen
wir wollen einen blick noch einmal auf
die karte werfen die wir eben gerade
gesehen haben das zentrum des erdbebens
stärke 7 liegt in der türkischen region
izmir auch übrigens ein ganz beliebter
urlaubsort und der griechischen insel
samos auch dort ein sehr beliebter
urlaubsort die stärke sieben ja sehr
sehr stark und vor allem auch 30
sekunden lang in der region gibt es
jetzt eine tsunami-warnung auch
grünen-politiker cem özdemir hat sich
jetzt per twitter zu wort gemeldet das
wollen wir ihnen hier kurz zeigen
katastrophen machen vor ländergrenzen
keine hält es hilft nur zusammenarbeit
meine gedanken sind bei den menschen in
der region um schlimmeres zu verhindern
muss jetzt schnell für die sicherheit
der menschen gesorgt werden
besonders auch in moria er bei mir ist
immer noch julian reichelt unser
chefredakteur
was sagst du zu diesem hinweis er
spricht die flüchtlingssituation in der
region an
das sind wahrscheinlich schlimmer weise
anzunehmen die menschen um die sich
jetzt mal wieder am wenigsten gekümmert
wird während dort häuser zusammenbrechen
und ein tsunami droht haben wir immer
noch katastrophale zustände in diesem
flüchtlingslager was glaubst du wie geht
die situation dort für diese menschen
weiter ja auch dass die karte die wir
eben gesehen haben ist nicht nur eine
karte die eines der beliebten
urlaubsgebiet der deutschen zeigt
sondern auch der teil unserer welt in
dem sich in den letzten fünf jahren die
flüchtlingskrise vor allem abgespielt
hat östlich also sozusagen auf der
rechten seite der karte sehen wir den
küstenstreifen türkei aus dem viele
flüchtlingsboote abgelegt haben um dann
richtung westen nur wenige kilometer und
die 30 kilometer über zu setzen und ein
neues leben in europa zu suchen
es gibt immer noch auf vielen dieser
inseln flüchtlingsunterkünfte oft
spärliche oft provisorische
flüchtlingsunterkünfte und ein phänomen
von naturkatastrophen ist natürlich
immer dass die menschen die davon
betroffen sind sich in allererster linie
dann um sich selbst kümmern um die firma
die solche katastrophen anrichten
kümmern müssen und dass die schwächsten
in dieser region natürlich die sind die
als allererste vergessen werden und das
ist vermutlich das was damals zu mir da
auch angesprochen hat und was in dieser
region natürlich jetzt auch droht mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren